natural forms what does this mean and so
I'm clear until I give you an example or
it sure will be an unnatural form and
then you'll see what was the thirties
yeah when we looked at yesterday we
looked at to a function the atom
together okay and then you get one wave
function not the other end to becomes
one what were the two differences number
one everything looks bigger that way and
number two okay so it was it was shifted
to a left all right okay now I think we
looked at this example sine X plus cos x
right the equal to actually equivalent
to use a better way to write it and we
convert it into sine X plus 5 all right
yes let's say to me yeah okay good now
this is all fine this looks kind of nice
I like is to consider what happens if we
got just a slightly different function
over the beginning here surprise move I
know supposes take instead of taking the
sum of these two functions we took the
difference right so sine minus cosine if
we were to do this again what would be
the R sine X plus alpha what form would
it be in okay so let's have a go with
this and we get into it just like we did
before instead every calculus we're
going to take this right hand side and
we're gonna expand it out okay all right
let's give this a go now expansion for
sine just a plus B okay sine x equals
cos x
that okay it's actually good yeah
question over there yeah no yeah okay
can wait till later then let's get the
coefficients all in the right spots
so this because I've got a minus sign
here right and I'm going to have a plus
sign over here I'm going to do something
a little bit unusual and write this as
sine X actually just one sine X right
and because I'm gonna have a plus over
here remember I'm going to compare
coefficients in a second right so
everything has to be equipment of both
sides so I'm gonna say plus negative one
lot solve cos x okay again do you have
to you have to do this line or but if I
say this enough times that you don't
just do things because you have to you
do it because it helps you solve the
question better okay right hand side
let's make the coefficient so they will
clear up I'm gonna have R cos alpha yeah
that corresponds to side and then I'm
gonna have a side okay now by comparison
you have to read something interesting
here okay when I take these knives
across right I'm gonna have aa cos alpha
being equal to one right but because of
this negative here right our sine alpha
is equal to minus one
I just pause hold on to that for a
second to work out alpha we're gonna
need to know what this R is the ohm to
the amplitude okay now just tell me I
think about what we looked at over here
this is the Sun right you add them up
and that's how far it goes what would
you guess to the amplitude of this was
bent the amplitude turns out to be the
same let me prove it to you okay where
did we get this odd number from okay we
took this equation let's call it 1 and
this equation call it two we squared
both and then when you get a close
squared and the science good together
okay
that cancels right so you get R squared
is 1 squared plus minus 1 squared okay
now if we don't like that to show you
that when I get to the next line I'm
gonna leave it in one single platform to
make something obvious this is square
root of this okay so more generally
speaking when you've got you know not
just specific numbers here but say a and
a B any coefficients you like okay your
amplitude here is the square root of a
squared plus B squared okay so it's
basically Pythagoras that's what it
comes for all right now I'm actually
gonna evaluate this that's one plus one
it's the same amplitude is that what you
had guessed the amplitude of this the
sum is the same as the amplitude of the
difference
please ponder that further well there's
my value for a two now bringing that
back to equations wanted to I'm going to
get here let's remove the are of the
other side I'm gonna get close our [ __ ]
is one on
- okay and I'm gonna get sine alpha B -
100 - okay and this is why by the way
some of you perhaps you may have met if
you've studied this you know ahead of
time or if you've seen this in shooting
or something like that you may have seen
people do this now look at these two
equations 1 & 2 in order to get out
alpha you actually sort of don't need to
know what R is because if you were
solving these simultaneously this isn't
the only way you can combine them what's
another way to combine equations 1 or 2
that just gets rid of our straight away
you could divine right now you can
divide 1 by 2 or 2 by 1 but it probably
makes more sense for us to go sign over
close because that's a ratio we're
familiar with right so if I go to
divided by 1 right the odds will cancel
sign-on calls will become a 10 right and
then what you get is well this will be B
over a so you might have seen this
before alongside this okay these are
kind of shortcut ways to get straight to
alpha and straight to your amplitude
okay but there's a danger with this and
it gets some highlighted by this year
okay cause alphas negative
sorry because that was positive sign
upwards now that tells you something
really important about the value of
alpha right think back to when you were
solving trig equations or something
really simple ones right
if cos is positive and sine is negative
where is it
so this tells you you know before we got
this X plus plan forth okay and that
value is a cute but this one's not going
to be it's going to be somewhere else
quite significant this number okay so
therefore this is what I put down there
the domain restriction on this is from
270 which is three-pound to up to 360
which is 2/5 okay you satisfied with
that so far
all right now where do I go from here
well I need to find some value of alpha
that satisfies both of these equations
right and it sits in this domain so what
would you pick
what's the basic angle or the related
angle sometimes it gets silent for so
you just think of exact values right so
100 you but obviously it can't be
playing for because that's not inside
this domain
so what's equivalent of platform in this
domain yeah it's it's going to be 2 pi
minus PI on 4 ok that's how you get
answers in the fourth quadrant so that
is I think it's at 7 power 4 okay so now
I've got my alpha now I've got my art so
I can actually answer the question I
could say the sine X minus cos x is
equivalent to where we get Richard sine
X plus 7
we have